l'ancien président barack obama poursuit
sa tournée médiatique après la
publication de ses mémoires
présidentielle un tome 1
c'est la semaine dernière que le 44e
président des états unis publié ce 1er
tome une terre promise
en 24 heures les premières 24 heures
près de 890 milles coq qui étaient
vendus on a demandé à mon prochain
éviter de lire pour nous je le joue à
los angelès allait mabanckou auteur
professeur de littérature et de langue
française à l'université de californie
écrivain bonsoir aller mabanckou plaisir
de vous retrouver
bonsoir et merci de mes invités dans
cette belle séquence à écouter mais
c'est pas beaucoup je fais quand même
une parenthèse parce que c'est ce
qu'obama souhaitait il a donné des
entrevues depuis quelques jours à la
presse américaine et il souhaitait une
transition pacifique comment avez-vous
réagi par ce fait même pas une heure et
demie con sic monsieur trump a dit allez
le feu vert il y aura une transition
pacifique finalement la fameuse
gestionnaire de des services
administratifs va pouvoir aller de
l'avant avec la transition oui vous avez
raison je crois que tron
donald trump a été en quelque sorte pris
la main dans le sac puisqu'il voulait à
tout prix qu'on ne puisse pas légitimer
les résultats du michigan mis le
michigan qui est le grand état qui lui
aurait permis de renverser les choses
reprendre les voir là bas avant d'aller
quêter celle de pennsylvanie il fallait
quatre ventes pour certifier les
résultats du mit et on en a eu trois
mais le quatrième c'est républicain qui
a suivi la ligne de donald trump et
finalement ils pouvaient plus âgés stade
il n'a plus fort que lui laissez vous
les choses se passaient telle qu'elle se
passe mais je me demande comment ça va
se passer est ce que il y aura cette
fameuse poignée d'humains en donald rang
et joe biden memopal est ce que je n'ai
pas d'ennemi alain mabanckou vend pas
serré la main ils vont porter le masque
ne sera peut-être pas le 20 janvier
cela dit la dernière fois qu'on s'est
parlé parce que je venais au livre dans
un instant parce que dans ce livre quand
même barack obama parle de deux pannes
et quand on a vu dans certains milieux
quand on ne veut un président noir
la dernière fois qu'on s'est parlé vous
parlez beaucoup de la georgie
or on sait que le match final la
dernière manche ça va se jouer le 5
janvier pour l'élection des deux
sénateurs est ce que dans notre champ
pas fait perdre des chances aux
républicains de gagner selon vous pas je
ne pense pas parce que les républicains
vivent aujourd'hui dans la trouille des
72 millions de dhs électeurs que donald
trump a dans son sac
donc personne ne faisait face et donald
trump le risque que donald trump puisse
donner des directives même pour
aujourd'hui ou demain
c'est pour ça qu'on voit les sénateurs
comme tête croze ou les marco rubio
porter les valises de 30 parce qu'ils
veulent être trompe à la place du temple
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas compris que 30 ne
laissera jamais à quelqu'un
l'héritage de ses 72 millions
d'électeurs c'est pour ça que je suis
aussi persuadé que en géorgie va se
jouer le destin même du parti
républicain qui aujourd'hui a montré
qu'il peut perdre son âme juste pour
gagner des élections alors que ils
auraient pu grandir en disons au
président écoute et c'est raté par
exemple dans le michigan
vous avez eu moins 14 fois moins de voix
que aujourd'hui joe biden mais personne
n'a parlé en dehors des des républicains
qui sont en retraite comme les mitt
romney et c'est pourquoi on peut pas
prendre on verra s'il ya quelqu'un qui a
des ambitions présidentielles qui va
oser parler pour redonner comme on dit
ici d'un petit coup de tassin placer un
peu transparent plus de 2024 revenons à
l'essentiel vous avez lu en anglais il
ya mon blé mais la règle et moi je les
geckos pêche et commence à le lire en
français ce une traduction très
parisienne pour dire vous voulez vous
l'écrivain vous le professeur de
littérature est ce que c'est le
président que vous avez reconnu à
travers ses 800 pages ou sceller un
écrivain c'est très délicat pour pour un
écrivain de pouvoir juger en fait les
mémoires les hommes politiques vivent
souvent dans cette sorte d'obsession de
laisser quelque chose à la postérité et
le lit
c'est la chose suprême pour eux ils
vivent toujours dans l'idée que même si
on oublie que j'étais président mais
j'ai laissé quelque chose à la postérité
qui servira comme de guide de gps pour
les générations futures et dans ce sens
dans ses 800 pages presque
barack obama est dans la même lancée
barack obama pense d'abord qu'il est
écrivain
il a raison de le penser barack obama
veut d'abord qu'on le voit en compte
l'écrivain c'est pour cela par exemple
pour aller présenter le livre en france
il n'est pas allé au tour d'une émission
politique qu'il a choisi une émission où
on a choisi l'émission littéraire par
excellence la grande librairie de
françois busnel sachant que il ce soir
ça c'est les écrivains il a honte est
aussi que les écrits glélé grand
président comme les turcs thilo 1953
avait reçu le prix nobel de la
littérature
obama lui elle a reçu le prix nobel de
la paix ce qui n'est pas toujours au
rien pour celui qui veut être écrivain
je pense par exemple à un autre
américain elie wiesel qui a toujours
rêvé d'avoir reçu le prix de nobel de la
paix au lieu de recevoir le prix nobel
de la littérature
or elie wiesel est un écrivain confirmé
un grand écrivain
mais pour barack obama ne va pas le
cacher la teinte est là les images sont
fortes les descriptions quand il parle
de sa famille quand il qu'il fait entrer
quelque chose quand il décrit les
personnages qu'on sent la pointe mais en
même temps aussi quand pour l'elysée il
est difficile de se détacher de l'aspect
politique et de la post une politique
qu'il incarne
à l'intérieur de ce livre notamment
qu'on sent que il est toujours en
campagne
je ne sais pas pour quel poste
probablement pour la postérité en même
temps et il dit avoir écrit ce livre il
y avait quand même trois ans et demi
et donc l'avoir écrit pour les jeunes
montrer ce que c'est que de devenir
président il pense à la présidence quoi
deux ans après avoir été élu au sénat
pour la première fois mais rien ne le
destinait à devenir président américain
quand même je viens de les destiner à
devenir président américain mais en même
temps il avait tous les ingrédients pour
faire la fameuse success story à
l'américaine
ouais c'est à dire que le papa un
africain qui est venue du kenya pour
venir faire les études aux états unis et
à prier a eu un enfant avec une femme
blanche fils à papa et ses bars et
retourne en afrique et il devait par la
grand-mère tout est décrit dans le sens
où vous avez vraiment la succès story
américaine qui va commencer il va
raconter sa vie il va raconter son
premier son accession au sénat en 2008
sa campagne vous avez tous les
ingrédients mais vraiment à l'américaine
ça ressemble à une sorte
d'autobiographie à l'américaine où
chaque détail même le goût n'est pas
parce que vous avez mangé leur est pas
le biscuit tout est à noter à la
différence de certains biographiques et
prennent plutôt les images mais ça reste
pour moi peut-être l'un l'une des plus
belles autobiographie où les mémoires
les plus impressionnants de la politique
américaine à ce jour
vous allez dans le sens de journalistes
américains fareed zakaria qu'ils aient
que pour lui c'est un livre
incontournable
alors pourquoi faut il faudrait lire
céline le premier temps pourquoi faut-il
le lire
le premier tome est important à lire
pour comprendre aussi paradoxalement de
naître est ce qu'on comprend la lecture
de ce livre que la naissance des donald
trump ne doit pas être prise comme une
certaine opération du saint-esprit où il
est tombé des nues comme ça ça se
préparer avec ce parti qu'on appelait le
parti le tea party qui étaient là on
pensait que c'était pour les changements
économiques mais en fait c'est un parti
qui était déjà en train de réveiller
l'amérique la plus odieuse qui était
dans une marmite plus tôt j'étais au
fond de la cuy
une et ce parti de ce type partie de ce
type article donald trump a put s'est
lui même quelque chose et on semble que
dans ses mémoires s'était immédiatement
d une photographie pour opposer deux
amériques une qui serait couverte et qui
serait populaire l'autre qui se
plongerait ou sert qu'au quai de virey
dans un certain racisme presque abscons
et c'est ça même l'avantagent le gros
point de ses mémoires c'est la
reconnaissance même parrot barack obama
lui même que son accession au pouvoir
est aussi un des éléments qui en fait
que aujourd'hui les états unis et donald
trump maintenant il faut attendre
qu'elles ont un peu éclipsé mémoire pour
qu'on voie ce qui est dit dans sa serre
un peu difficile pour lui d'écrire je
pense à trouver des dernières scènes du
livre c'est leur famille jean et de la
presse là où il peut il
il fait de l'humour au détriment de
donald trump allez merci beaucoup
d'avoir lu la terre promise pour nous et
on se reparle très bientôt vous êtes
devenu un ami de l'émission c'est
certain merci beaucoup
alors au revoir au revoir